for the most part we try not to touch
the business for the first six months
maybe even up to a year get everything
resettled everything's fine everyone
realizes we're not you know terrible
people are gonna come in and bulldoze
the company right and then it's like
okay what could we go to work on and the
way we think about that is the lower the
frequency and the higher the impact the
more we want to operate in that space
so if it's low frequency and high impact
example would be rebranding a company
building a completely new online lead
generation program
um maybe re-incentivizing the sales team
hiring a new Chief technology officer
right these are things that are very low
frequency hopefully if you do them right
a business shouldn't have that
competency in-house
so the more that we can see across a
portfolio right with 13 portfolio
companies we see a lot over them and we
can locate Talent on our staff that is
unusual to have in any one of the
businesses but that's helpful to all the
businesses at various times during the
life cycle of the business
all right guys bang bang I've got Brent
here with me I thought a great place to
start would be you were somebody who is
pretty well known with tech
entrepreneurs with the investment
community and with what I'll call boring
businesses or traditional businesses
yeah
um how do you decide where to allocate
capital in terms of uh those different
buckets but also in terms of where you
think that you can gain an advantage or
somehow Drive outside's returns yeah
when you look at our firm permit Equity
it looks like we're a generalist firm so
we've got investments in manufacturing
and construction and business services
we had a military recruitment firm we
own a matchmaking firm which we can talk
about like really diverse group of
companies you look at these and you say
what what could those all have in common
we consider ourselves specialists in
what we call adolescent businesses so
too big to be small too small to be big
these are businesses that are Main
Street America
um they're doing they're building pools
they're building fences I said doing
real things
um and we like to get involved with
people who want to do things long term
so we have really long-term capital
um typically we're involved in three
plus million dollars of earnings so much
higher Revenue than that
um so these are not like small
businesses uh at least you know like the
bagel shop but it's um these are legit
companies and we try to be good
long-term partners and good long-term
stewards so typically buying them with
no debt uh no intention of selling them
and um trying to treat people really
well long term so before we get into how
you guys do this let's talk about some
of the businesses uh we maybe we can
start with the pool business is one of
the older businesses that I think that
you've owned for a while now describe a
little bit as to like what that business
does and why that fits the Mandate of
what you guys are looking for yeah so we
always have these uh kind of short ways
of thinking about these businesses so we
said people have been dipping their
bodies in water for pleasure for
thousands of years we think they'll
continue to do so so we're not worried
about some new app or AI you know
adjusting the market in such a way
that's going to cause people to not want
to to uh throw a pool party in their
backyard
so that's kind of the Baseline uh we
think Phoenix Arizona and Tucson which
are the locations of the businesses we
think they'll probably grow and it's
only getting hotter so out there you
know you think about a pool in Wisconsin
it's a luxury item right you're
typically going to use a pretty short
period of time of year you get further
south you're going to use them more
often Phoenix Arizona it's like a
utility I mean you have people who uh
you know have fairly small homes who
still want a pool because it's the only
way to cool down in the summer keep
their kids entertained make memories
around pools right so um yeah we got
involved with that business in 2016
um and really just helped them continue
to grow the business and modernize it um
you know we think a lot about we call
like quality of earnings not just
quantity of earnings so you can look and
ultimately the quantity will show up you
know as a function of the quality over
time but in the short term is kind of
hard to tell and so with all these
businesses we're trying to get in there
and think about you know how do we
create stability to serve their
customers to be a great place to be an
employer to serve our uh suppliers
really well and be a good long-term
partner to the community and so that's
what we try to do and when you talk
about modernize the business is that
like a technology and tools type thing
is that like hey we want to go in and
train whether it is the management team
or their employees like how do you
modernize it yeah so there's a layer of
business we call it the everything
tastes like chicken layer right which it
doesn't matter if you're doing
matchmaking or pool building or
recruiting for the military it's going
to be the same set of tools that you
need across the uh across the firm so
marketing advertising uh lead generation
sales
technology stack so you know like what's
your software that you're using
accounting Finance
HR and then kind of benefits the back
office type things so if you look at all
those no business has ever been good at
all of those things no small business at
least and um as we like to say small
businesses don't say small on purpose
right there's a reason why they're small
so we like to do is get involved with
businesses who are great at the thing
that they do and maybe need help in
these other areas so for the pool
business we were able to Institute a
really robust online lead generation
program when we came into that business
basically weren't generating any leads
online and they just weren't high
quality leads we were able to come in
and help them build that new program and
now well online leads are the dominant
that way in which they get business so
things like that I mean of course
reorganization of the management team
when we came into the business there was
a lot of people doing kind of
overlapping jobs and we said hey totally
reasonable when you're smaller as you
start to get bigger you have to
specialize so we're asking people about
you know what is the next in line
succession succession planning look like
for the business
um you know can we separate roles can we
get more uh specialized talent in
different roles things like that really
proud of that team they've done a great
job of building out the leadership team
over time and really building the
business so on a business like this uh
you all come in and obviously there's a
capital injection into the business and
there is a very unique alignment for
long-term growth and kind of continue to
compound capital for that long period of
time but how much of it is like
spreadsheet analysis and understanding
of the business like let's move these
numbers versus there are the people
components and the ability to uh you
know work with a management team you
aren't there every day right and how do
you kind of balance between like what I
would call like the spreadsheet versus
the people and how do you guys evaluate
which one's more important maybe you
guys you initially look at a company
that you might want to actually buy
that's a great question uh for us and
this isn't probably true for most of the
industry for us it's 99 people one
percent sort of the math um in fact
We've joked that if you can't get the
math to work on the back of a napkin
it's not going to work in a spreadsheet
I mean literally because we're not using
any debt typically in these transactions
so the math is super easy right it's
what do we think the business is going
to generate in free cash flow what
multiple are we paying based on that
what type of yield are we starting from
what do we do with the cash if there's
cash that's generated how do we reinvest
it at what types of rate of return can
we reinvest it but that math I mean
literally we could get a piece of paper
and model it out in about 30 seconds on
the back of the napkin
um the people are infinitely complicated
I'm messy you're messy turns out when
you get a bunch of messy people together
it's a mess right and so we really try
to spend time if we're going to partner
with these companies for decades which
is Our intention
it's going to take a lot of life to be
lived together and we want to make sure
that we're starting from a really good
foundation in a good place and so you
know oftentimes those discussions will
start with the seller what are your
goals you know one of the questions we
like to ask is if you could wave a magic
wand and create the perfect scenario
over the next 5 10 15 years what does
that look like some sellers will say
look I want to be out in a year okay
great let's all work towards that that's
a goal that we have let's all work
towards that goal some will say you know
I think I can give it three to five
years like let's kind of keep talking uh
maybe I can step into an executive
chairman role maybe eventually just be
an advisor to the business fantastic
what we say is there's no right or wrong
answer to any of these we just want to
know if the truth is and we all want to
be on the same page and make sure that
truth doesn't change over time and if it
does like raise your hand and make sure
to tell us
um we promise not to surprise them yes
they promise not to surprise us
most the time works out pretty well yeah
it's uh what is it like happiness is
really just expectations in reality and
the the closer those two things are ends
up actually uh increasing happiness same
thing here with success of the business
correct yeah
um so that is a business that I think
most people would look at as uh you know
an atoms based business it is very much
in the real world it's tangible You're
Building physical pools Etc
um you have another business which is
matchmaking which I don't think most
people are like I bet you Brent is gonna
get into the match talk a little bit as
to like why this business specifically
is unique and how you guys think about
the similarities and differences between
pool building and then the matchmaking
business yeah it's a fascinating
business um I in a million years I never
would have guessed we would have been in
the matchmaking business
um in fact uh Emily who leads our deal
team I remember coming to my office and
saying okay hey I need to sit down shut
up
don't say a word I'm gonna tell you some
stuff about this business you're going
to come to conclusions they're incorrect
right
she she sits down like all right all
right what could she be you know she's
she launches about three sets and I was
like stop there's no way she's like I
told you and I was like that's for sure
a hooker business like that's for sure
there's no way that this is a legitimate
thing right
not at all it was absolutely legitimate
it's actually
um it's actually turned out to be one of
those businesses where when I think
about what the work they actually do it
is an incredible net benefit to the
world
um they are helping people find the love
of their life and you know it's not a
dating service so this is not like hey
set up a bunch of dates for me this is a
matchmaking business which again when I
first learned about it I was like I
didn't know the difference
what could it be think about executive
Search so if you're in business you
typically retained a search firm to go
hire you uh some specific role typically
it's going to be an executive role so
how does that process play out you
identify what you're looking for what
are the roles responsibilities all these
different things you then out go out you
Source a bunch of candidates through a
firm right that goes out find so many
people that contacts them they say hey
how you how do you like your job what
are you thinking about all that
corollary is not exactly same here but
for the most part they go out and do the
exact same thing so they say hey you
know what are you looking for what
what's interesting to you and some
people are very broad with it they're
like look I'm looking for a man between
the age of I don't know 35 and 50 who is
a professional who lives kind of within
300 miles of my home now that's it right
like great
um some people are very specific we had
a gentleman who had lost his wife
tragically
um wanted to remarry down the road he
was an excellent golfer so he said hey
not only age and all these other things
but I wanted to be an under seven
handicapped golfer
literally
and you think about it it's like for his
lifestyle right I think it's something
he loves it's a deep passion of his he
loves playing golf he loved to travel
the world to play golf
so how do you find somebody who not only
has all these other things but also as a
seven handicapped golfer under right
will you partner with country clubs and
you partner with Golf Digest and I mean
a bunch of these Publications to try to
go out and find this person you place
ads literally saying hey if this sounds
like you come out of the woodwork right
sure enough he's happily married no way
it's amazing right so what they're
really trying to do is they're trying to
find the right person for you and that
can either be relatively easy I mean
it's always going to be his executive
Search kind of program it's always going
to be you know a higher level of touch
and service and interviews and there's
only one introduction at a time both
have to opt out before you move on to
the next one so this is not again like a
dating service it's not I'm gonna go to
a city and set up a bunch of dates it's
not at all what they do this is an
in-depth process to try to find you the
right person and I mean I haven't seen
the stats recently I know it used to be
sixty percent of the time the first
person they put in front of you was the
right one that's how much work is done
wow 87 of the time if you you sign up
for the service it's called selective
search 87 of the time you end up in a
long-term committed monogamous
relationship 87 of the time I mean
that's incredible if you think about
that for a second so yes it's expensive
just like executive Search is expensive
is it worth it
yeah our clients are thrilled with the
results how much is it
well so it sounds shocking when I first
say it I mean
yeah exactly sit down for a second so it
starts at about fifty thousand dollars
and our largest contracts go above over
a million dollars and you say what in
the world to find a spouse like can't
you just go on Tinder or go to a bar or
sure I think there are plenty of uh
people out there who
um that doesn't work for and the people
who we work with are busy professionals
um people who travel a lot people who
have a uh unusual lifestyle
um and uh people who some of them are
well-known celebrity types who just
really frankly can't meet somebody
without wondering if they're with them
for them or with them for what they have
and so
um you know the price for them is well
worth it and we love to serve them when
there is somebody who is well known
whether it's a business person a
celebrity whatever uh is there some
masking of who they are at first or is
there just like you know hey somebody
contacts you and they're like by the way
uh do you want to talk to celebrity a
yeah no type thing yeah it's incredibly
masked I mean until the very end I mean
the person's really not going to know
um because what they say is it doesn't
matter who the person's name is we're
going to tell you about them everyone's
interests are aligned to make sure that
there's a good match there so they're
going to talk about you know they have
an unusual lifestyle they're traveling a
lot maybe they have requirements for
their job that aren't typical those
types of things they'll describe the
lifestyle they'll describe kind of the
personality they'll talk to them about
generally what they look like and then
ultimately if they end up being a match
I mean there's only one person at a time
that's matched so the only person who
knows about that person is the person is
matched yeah it um it's traveling all
the time as an example is one of those
things that I think a lot of folks like
oh yeah that sounds amazing and then if
you have to think about it you're like
you know what I don't know if I want to
travel 300 days out of the year like
actually I may want to just be at home
and somebody that lifestyle isn't for me
and so there are little things like that
that I'm sure I'm sure end up being a
great filter for the different folks
so we have pools with matchmaking
you also have a fence building business
yeah yeah talk about the fence building
business I think this is like a good
example of like literally you guys look
at businesses across different
Industries but what's going on with the
fences yeah so fences so it's uh is Ace
Fence in uh Dallas Texas
um incredible team started 40 years ago
uh by great family and um we think
they're the largest fence builder in the
country so they build
um wood residential fences they'll do
some metal working
um it's a great team I mean they do
exactly what you think they just do it
at incredible volume I think they did
average like 88 fences a day last year
um so huge volume uh in the DFW area and
um they put your fence up make sure it's
30. so 88 fences a day sounds like an
absurd number right
um are they like speed fence Builders is
DFW area just so large and so many
fences are going up that they have like
one percent of the market like how do
you get because a couple things probably
have to happen there to get to 88 fences
a day right it's incredibly difficult
right you have to build this business
over like I said 40 years to get to that
so they're going in and finishing whole
neighborhoods typically at a time so
they'll work with a uh a builder and the
Builder will have you know they're
putting up say 500 or 800 or a thousand
homes in this big area the fences are
typically the last thing to go in so the
Nuance of it is you could probably try
to save money by by hiring a cheap fence
Builder right the problem is if that
fence Builder is delayed you don't get
paid for the house right so actually it
being the last thing you know our
working capital is almost nothing
because we finished the fence the house
gets done boom everyone gets paid right
so it's a really interesting that's in
in evaluating these businesses there's a
lot of businesses that look one way on
the surface they look similar and when
you dig into them the Dynamics of the
underlying economics the working capital
really the business model in general was
completely different right so we're
actually we'll do a little bit direct to
Consumer but hardly any most time we're
working with big Builders and trying to
really service their needs to finish out
these uh big neighborhoods when a
business been around for 40 years like
that what are some of the Dynamics as
you guys come in I'm assuming there's
family Dynamics there's probably people
who have been there for a long time who
aren't part of the family but they see
this as an opportunity to grab power
cause problems like all kinds of the
people stuff like what what have you
experienced and you know trying to
mitigate as much of those risks as
possible yeah well broadly I mean the
Ace Fence in particular the the deal the
fence company uh really great family we
didn't run into many Dynamics there
um we have over the years though
I it's it's funny I have uh I don't know
how many hundreds of side visits I've
been on at this point I mean I had one
where
um a guy invited his entire family for
over for dinner because uh I offered to
buy him dinner and he was like well how
many people can come and I was like I
thought it was just maybe you your wife
we could talk about the deal and he was
like would you mind if I bring a few
family members it was like Thanksgiving
dinner he hosted on my tab you know
things like that that's what kind of
thing yeah it was I was like oh that's
an interesting interesting way to get a
free dinner how many people do you think
showed up oh it's like nine I think nine
people there he started arguing about uh
you know about family stuff and icon was
there just like eating my food and I was
like all right guys well did you do the
deal later no it did not do the deal no
um yeah uh it there are a tremendous
number of Dynamics I mean you can
imagine after 40 years
um every business has challenges and
like I said every business is deficient
in some areas right I mean there's just
no way that a business is going to be a
10 out of 10 in every one of the key
areas you needed to be if we do our job
right the people we partner with and
this is what really tend to suss out
during the process is are they really
good at the thing that they do and Ace
Fence being a good example of that they
are incredible they are the best in the
market by a mile Maya would argue best
in the country at building residential
fences I have it down to a science
incredible well-oiled machine still
plenty of problems like anything else
but they have opportunities to expand
into new technologies to expand into
adjacent geographies
um to create a lot of efficiencies in
how they work and um we're excited about
that right we want to build for the long
term so one of the things that always
cracks me up about uh people who are
like I'm gonna go buy some business is I
can imagine let's take defense business
as an example uh somebody shows up and
they're like huh you guys build fences
you ever thought doing it in the town
next door as well
[Laughter]
crazy new strategy yeah like the owner's
like I've been doing this for 40 years I
literally have thought about all of the
you know what I mean like I've literally
obsessed over fences I could tell you
you know the uh uh degree at which if
the fence post is off what the you know
uh the hill correct uh you know degree
or whatever like
how do you avoid kind of being the you
know the person who shows up and is like
I got the good idea versus like hey you
guys actually know what to do like we
kind of want to be support maybe to some
degree where's the balance there or how
do you think about finding that balance
yeah we just try to take an incredibly
High humility approach and what we say
to them you know people will ask us like
what are you gonna do for us
we say nothing
they're like what do you mean nothing
like like count on nothing from us
nothing other than just being a good
long-term Steward of the business will
be great Partners to you we'll write you
a check check will clear and we'll show
up and we'll try to be helpful to you
but we can't tell you what we're going
to be helpful on right like until you
get behind the curtain you have no idea
I mean due diligence you know the the
phase before you buy the business where
you're trying to really explore what
what am I really buying what are the
challenges with it um what are maybe the
opportunities I don't care how much
diligence you could be in due diligence
on a deal for five years I mean honestly
and you would show up day one you start
learning new things it's just different
once you aren't in the owner's seat than
before so what we try to do is we don't
have a 90-day Playbook we don't have a
goals for the company when we come in we
ask the leadership team hey what do you
think we should learn we don't know what
you do you're the experts not us
um so we're coming in with the exact
opposite mentality I think than
traditional private equity which is like
hey we know exactly what I do this
business get on board we're going to try
to ramp this thing up and then we're try
to sell it within a short period of time
right that's the exact opposite of us so
we're just trying to get to know the
business trying to get to know the
people trying to develop trust because
look if if I bought your business right
and we didn't know each other it would
take you a while for me to say something
and for you to be like is this guy full
of it or not right does he know what
he's talking about or not and vice versa
right I don't know where the edges of
your knowledge are edges of your
competency right so it takes a little
while to kind of get to a rhythm there
are exceptions to this but for the most
part we try not to touch the business
for the first six months maybe even up
to a year get everything resettled
everything's fine everyone realizes
we're not you know terrible people are
gonna come in and bulldoze the company
right and then it's like okay what could
we go to work on and the way we think
about that is the lower the frequency
and the higher the impact the more we
want to operate in that space so if it's
low frequency and high impact example
would be rebranding a company building a
completely new online lead generation
program
um maybe re-incentivizing the sales team
hiring a new Chief technology office sir
right these are things that are very low
frequency hopefully if you do them right
um a business shouldn't have that
competency in-house
so the more that we can see across a
portfolio right with 13 portfolio
companies we see a lot over them and we
can locate Talent on our staff that is
unusual to have in any one of the
businesses but that's helpful to all the
businesses at various times during the
life cycle of the business so we have a
full-time executive recruiter on staff
that's all she does day in and day out
is help find Talent it's incredibly
valuable for her it would make no sense
to locate that at any one of the
companies yeah when you think about
incentives one of the things that I've
seen you talk a lot about I know that
you think deeply about incentives is
something that Warren Buffett Charlie
Bunger Charles Koch all these people who
have built these huge huge you know
businesses whether they are single
companies whether they own a bunch of
subsidiaries whether they're acquiring
businesses like incentives drive so much
of what happens in business how do you
think about me we can go top down right
the incentives of your organization in
terms of you have some outside Capital
but you've done some unique things with
the life cycle of the phone and uh the
management fee Etc like how did you kind
of design the incentives where you felt
it put you guys in the best position
yes great question
um the goal that I've always had is to
align incentives as much as you possibly
can up and down the stack right so if
you think about it we want the portfolio
companies to be focused on long-term
cash generation right how do you develop
long-term cash generation you have a
good quality and quantity of earnings
you establish a great culture and you
incentivize them hey if there's a great
thing to do with a dollar to reinvest it
if you can invest it at a high
probability and a high return absolutely
keep the dollar we don't want it right
if you can't the worst possible thing
you can do is to hold on to it so same
thing at the permanent Equity level our
level
um you know we take no fees of any kind
no reimbursements of any kind there's no
cash that comes from either the
portfolio companies or from our
investors to the GP so the general
partner being permanent Equity the
people that do the work on the deal
um outside of we take a percentage of
free cash flow above a hurdle once the
cash of the business starts generating
out now you might say well doesn't that
incentivize you then to strip the
companies for as much cash as you
possibly can no because if we think
there's a great opportunity to take a
dollar and get a 25 return in every
subsequent year we'd be insane to take
that dollar out right we want to
continue to compound that in the in the
businesses so up and down the stack
right we're aligned with our investors
they want cash ultimately out of the
investment we want to get paid and our
our portfolio companies want to make
money too we're all incentivized to
basically reinvest when it makes sense
and to not reinvest when it doesn't and
because we're not in it for the fees
right we're not getting that you know
two and twenty on getting the two
um we don't have fee you know we don't
have the incentive to raise more and
more Capital
um the interesting part is uh when you
actually and maybe there's a little bit
of a digression away from like sort of
the capital stack
um I agree
very broadly with Buffett Monger Coke
all these all these people who are you
know big advocates for incentives and of
course we believe in it we want the
right incentives we don't want the wrong
incentives
the thing I think that a lot of
employers and business owners get into
hot water with is they think they're
like okay I want my sales team to sell
more
well I clearly if I just gave them
better incentives they would sell more
right the question you got to ask
yourself when you're changing incentives
on somebody is okay what are the things
that they're currently doing that I
don't want them to do
okay and am I incentivizing them to do
those things that I don't want them to
do
and what are things they're currently
not doing that I want them to do and am
I not incentivizing those things when
you strip it down like that a lot of
comp changes because I've seen you know
a lot of business owners will Tinker
with all kinds of compensation search
they're constantly adjusting all these
things and turns out that people just
keep doing what they've been doing for a
long time it seems like you can't crack
that nut it's because they like what
they're doing the employees are focused
on what they're doing they're working
hard and
doing a good job right there's not much
more you can turn somebody right it's
only if you see something in the capital
structure right in how you're
incentivizing them that would cause them
to do something you don't want them to
do so it's like I would say incentives
are wildly important at a very high
level
um and at a micro level often are not as
important as you might think or at least
in the the way to incentivize people
isn't going to create the most change
the way you think it will yeah it's this
weird thing where uh I have seen sales
teams specifically people will try to
change some of those incentives but it's
almost like time is being wasted talking
about all the incentive changes rather
than just getting out talking to more
potential customers right exactly and so
like yes you could get another pointer
to uh when it comes to the commission
but if you just had spent that time
selling maybe you would have actually
made more on an aggregate dollar basis
because this the original commission
would have actually reaped more because
you had more sales yeah yeah I mean like
an example that we we like across our
portfolio broadly to have sales people
incentivize based on uh gross profit and
not based on revenue for obvious reasons
like that's just something when we look
at uh look at a sales team we're like
okay is the in sales team incentivized
based on Revenue if so we probably want
to make a change right because there's
all kinds of things if you if your
incentive is based on Revenue right and
you cut the price five percent
doesn't really matter to your commission
right it's a five percent it's not like
that big a deal you'd rather get the
sale if by cutting it five percent
you're eating into 25 of the margin that
matters a lot more so you again always
want to just align the incentives
between the parties to make sure that
there's no uh heads I win tails you lose
or vice versa so when you do something
like that like that I think it's a very
tangible example right so you go in
sales team is incentivized on the
revenue side you now are going to say
hey we're actually going to do it on
this kind of gross profit uh type uh
metric do you have to switch the team
out or have you found that usually you
could go in and you explain it and they
say okay cool I got it I understand why
this is happening and you have to maybe
explain to them how they can make more
money doing it or something but like the
existing team usually can weather and be
okay with the incentive change or is it
something where you go in and you're
like look no matter how hard we try
we're gonna have to find new people
because they're just so anchored on this
other system or this other metric that
uh that their compensation is based on
which is an emotional thing yeah of
course what's been the experience there
yeah the experience is um if you're not
changing magnitude of compensation
people are very flexible if you start
changing magnitude is when it gets
really weird right so we've not come
into a company frankly and said oh the
amount they're compensating people we
just need to slash that because we think
we should be able to retain more of that
profit for ourselves that's not
something we do we don't think that's a
really kind thing to do we don't think
that's long term so oftentimes what
we're doing is we're coming in and
saying okay look here's how much you
made based on what you sold here's the
amount of Revenue that you um you you
know sold last year we're gonna move you
to a gross profit this would have been
the amount of gross profit you have sold
and by the way it's about in the same
ballpark as the amount of money you
would have made last year if you do la
this year what you did last year but
here's the upside for you if you can
sell more in gross profit here's how
this works out better for you in the
long term and so we're always trying to
show them you're basically not going to
go backwards from where you are and
there's upside from there because we
think that is as you understand more
about the gross profit profile of the
business us we understand that we think
that it'll be better for you and
actually to be honest better for
customers oftentimes we've seen that a
number of times in the business where we
change the incentive structure for a
sales team and actually sales go up they
don't just stay flat they actually go up
because everyone understands what's
going on so we violated one of the rules
of the tech industry we've been using
the p word profit uh obviously that is
something that doesn't get talked about
a lot I heard somebody recently say that
in San Francisco everyone talks about
growth rate not ebitda right and uh
maybe actually and the opposite on Wall
Street everyone talks about ebitda not
growth rate
um but in the midwest we talk about cash
in cash even better even better but what
uh I remember reading at one point um
early on uh the Koch brothers when they
took over uh cook Industries and they
were going to grow it uh there was a
specific data point where they basically
made I don't know if it's a legal
agreement but I think it was more of
like kind of a brotherly agreement we're
not going to take uh more than 10 of
profits out of this business reinvest at
least ninety percent every single year
and we're going to compound this thing
now that is like a very strict kind of
mathematical formula they came up with
how do you guys think about uh
reinvesting and then also it's
interesting because you can reinvest in
the individual businesses right so if
your pool business is generating a lot
of cash or the fence business is
generally a lot of cash but you also
have the ability to pull up it into the
GP and then either redeploy it into New
Opportunities maybe into other companies
that you already own or pull it out of
the business like there's a couple of
different layers to reinvestment versus
uh maybe you know uh kind of harvesting
that uh profit how do you think about
that yeah well so the nice thing is
we're incredibly long-term and we
typically don't use debt in our
transactions so all the free cash flow
is truly free meaning we can do whatever
we want with it that's an amazing
starting point we can talk about
examples of how that really helped I
mean owning an aerospace business as an
example in covid I don't know if you
know this but Aerospace doesn't go down
as an industry it just never goes down
and when you buy an aerospace business
in 2019 which is what we did
for an industry that never goes down and
then all of a sudden the industry's down
85 90 percent wow right massive shock
wave through the system
um thank God we didn't use debt and we
had free cash flow it's truly free to be
able to well do whatever we wanted with
which in that case allowed us to grow a
ton
um what did you do there in like in that
situation yeah well so in that specific
one so uh Pacific air Industries and air
cert are two kind of sister companies
they work hand in hand
um uh led by Jason harp out in Los
Angeles
um incredible business they they are uh
we joke they're kind of like a hedge
fund for airplane Parts they uh they buy
large Lots so you know
um let's say FedEx is changing out their
platforms they're going to switch from
one type of plane to another type of
plane well you're buying tremendous
number of parts to constantly be
replacing right in the different life
cycles of these uh aircraft
and so they'll take all those parts
spare parts that they had used for the
old platform and instead of like doing a
you know yard sale with it and be like
you know that wouldn't make any sense
they'd bulk it all together and they say
Okay who wants to buy it right so we're
a liquidator of large lots of airplane
Parts uh we'll sometimes hold we
actually I I was uh with the CEO a
couple days ago and he said that we
recently sold a part that was uh we had
in our warehouse for over 30 years wow
over 30 years to a uh to a a group in in
Africa that's flying DC tens so
incredible how much uh diversity of
airplane parts we have
in that business
um because we didn't have any debt all
of our competitors were loaded up with
debt so the model was not only do you
have operational debt but you got huge
lines of credit to buy all these
airplane parts and you're trying to you
know especially when capital is cheap
you know you buy with very little cost
of capital and then you're trying to
churn them as fast as you can which is
great until there's a massive slowdown
in the business and cost of capital
starts going up so that would never
happen that would never happen I mean
again the airline airplane Parts
business just never goes down right it
always either stays flat or goes up
um and so yeah we were in this really
interesting spot where we said okay we
are one of the few people in the
industry who has the ability to make
reinvestments
um do we want to try to cash flow this
out do we want to try to be conservative
and just kind of hunker down do we want
to do what everyone else is doing and
lay off a bunch of staff and and sort of
you know go into a wintry State
um or do we want to go hyper aggressive
you know Zig when everyone else is
zagging and what we chose to do is that
and so we got aggressive in this little
time any airplane Parts business started
hiring some of the top talent in the
industry and said hey come join our
ragtag group of people and let's go try
to change things implemented a brand new
Erp system basically did like 10 years
of modernization in 18 months it was
incredible to see and now coming out the
other side of it I mean the airplane
business is not back to where as an
industry back to where it has been it
probably is going to be another year or
two my guess would be before it's back
fully but we're up tremendously because
of the changes that were made and the
talent that we've added so having that
flexibility this is where we get a lot
of crap from uh the industry about how
can the world can you guys generate you
know even market returns when the you
know three turns of debt right having a
balance sheet that's at least 50 percent
dead is kind of the norm in the private
Equity business I mean that's
conservative 50 some balance sheets are
80 percent debt you know how are we
thinking about generating returns when
we're not using any debt just doesn't
make sense except for if you look and
say okay what if the optionality of that
not having that debt provides the cash
to be able to reinvest back into areas
of the business so what we say to our
portfolio companies to answer your
original question was
if you've got a great place to put cash
we want you to put it there so high
probability High return opportunities we
absolutely want you to retain the cash
generate
those Investments right because in every
subsequent out year we're going to be
benefiting from that investment if you
don't have a good place to put it for
God's sakes don't keep it you're right
send it back out and so it's really that
simple we just set a high bar in the in
the portfolio and we say you can if you
can generate better than that with a
good probability go for it if you can't
send it up and out
you all look at some of these businesses
that are
tens of millions of dollars that you're
going to write a check could be single
digit billions I'm assuming if you found
the right one given the capital Partners
you guys have you could go after a
really really big opportunity or
whatever
how do you spend your time looking for
the businesses right so you know I was
telling you earlier that like I think a
lot of folks uh when they go look for a
home online it's like okay I want uh a
thousand to two thousand square feet I
want you know two to four bedrooms and
uh it has to be within this geographic
location or a 30 mile radius or whatever
there's a lot of sites where you go look
at buying businesses online you can do
the exact same thing kind of filter with
these preset uh um kind of uh
constraints for you all the constraints
seem a little bit less rigid and so that
means that you could look at literally
thousands of companies how do you know
where to focus yeah uh we do look at
thousands of companies and uh to be
honest this is one of the hardest parts
we have to we have to get up to speed
very quickly on a lot of different
Industries we've seen a lot through the
years right so I mean there's really a
business that comes to us that we say
we've actually never looked at the
specific sector although a business that
we're getting ready to buy we had never
really looked at it prior to it
um so it does happen I it sounds
daunting honestly how do we find
opportunities that come to us at this
point so we have an incredible Network
that we've developed over time and we're
kind of one of the only players in the
industry that does it the way we do it
so we say to an intermediary right
broker Investment Bank is look if you're
going to show this to 500 people and
they really don't care who buys the
business
don't don't bring it to us
um you know our tagline that we kind of
we talk about a lot is you know we're
for business owners who care what
happens next
so if you care what happens next I think
we're a really good partner I don't
think you'll find a higher quality
partner than us but look if you're going
to sell 100 of the business and you
could care less about the future of the
business or the employees and they're
going to write you a check they're like
it should just be a straight auction
it's like selling your house like do you
really care who lives in your house
after you leave it
probably not most people don't I mean
maybe a few exceptions
um
businesses are a little bit different
businesses the entire potentially
generations of family members are
working there
um the name is on the door right these
are Community employers these are people
who care deeply about Way Beyond the
dollars and if we've done our job right
um we have a joke that we like to say
which is if you haven't gotten Rich
doing it we're not going to right so
like we want to buy a business from
somebody who's probably already wealthy
so you know
if money is the top thing then we're
probably not going to be the right fit
no matter what and so that mentality
gets the right people to come inbound us
now we pay market prices or we wouldn't
get a deal done
but we're probably if you're going to
put it out to bid to a number of people
we're probably not going to be quite the
highest bid but the quality of what
we're going to offer is a lot higher
when you think about buying something
from somebody who's already wealth and
it's a great kind of heuristic right of
like hey look if you made money we have
a shot at making money right uh but if
not then obviously not
um how is it dealing with the wealthy
business owner and buying their business
versus if you were buying it from
someone who I'll use wealth maybe as a
proxy for sophistication but maybe
that's the wrong way to think about it
yeah
um it looks like a no it's really not
it's funny because um we've met some
incredibly sophisticated sellers who are
to be honest I mean have made good money
I mean we're talking about here in in
the range of like for normal America
good to Great like I mean these are sort
of the low end would be like the
chairman of the country club right I
mean these are like very very wealthy by
any standards nationally internationally
to like extremely wealthy right
um because if you start a business and
you know the business we just bought
like they started in their garage it was
nothing for decades I mean they slowly
compounded so this is not somebody who's
like you know born with a silver spoon
in their mouth I mean these are
hard-working construction people these
are blue collar businesses typically
we're getting involved in for the most
part and
um look the rewards are great that if
you can compound something for 40 years
treat your customers well treat your
employees well be a great Community
member yeah good things happen you know
it just takes 40 years so if you've got
40 years and a lot of grit willing to
endure a lot of pain you can actually
start a pretty big business right so
yeah some of them are very sophisticated
and small some of them are not
sophisticated and large I would say
they're all if you're going to start a
business and you're going to operate a
business for that long you're all
sophisticated in in some ways I would
say summer more sophisticated like you
know book smarts versus Street smarts
um we just love working with people and
the difference in geography I mean we've
got business across the country
differences in culture amongst those
it's so much fun so what's interesting
about this is um I think it was Forbes
recently uh had kind of a 15-minute
video uh profile and when they
interviewed this guy uh and if I
remember correctly I believe that he
lives in Arkansas he's the only
billionaire in Arkansas which
immediately you think billionaire in
Arkansas right people start saying well
what does he do and so this uh gentleman
if I remember all the details it was
like his wife's family had a plot of
land and the way he described it was the
accountant said to them you're land rich
and cash poor right sure and so they got
some trouble they basically sold
everything off except for this one
little six acre plot of land which
happened to have a wood treatment
facility on it
and this wood treatment facility he
decided that he was going to try to run
it but he was a lawyer so he was going
to work uh he'd wake up super early 4 35
o'clock in the morning he'd go out there
he had one employee he would help him
get everything ready for the day he'd
then go home shower go work his job as a
lawyer do that until about 4 35 o'clock
they'd go back help the guy finish the
rest of the work he does day in day out
for years had a very hard time getting
the business off the ground
while sir sure he fast forward 30 years
or whatever it's been and uh this
gentleman is the owner of Yellowwood
which is y-e-l-l-a wood which is the
number one wood treatment uh products
and uh facility in the entire country if
I understand it correctly the reason why
it's so interesting is because he is now
the only billionaire in his State and so
if you're the only billionaire in a
state immediately most of America would
think well this guy must be balling he
must be driving you know a Ferrari he
has a private jet and a yacht and all
stuff I don't know if he does or not but
he has stayed in that same 2 000 person
town and a big piece of this was him and
his business have basically helped to uh
redevelop and kind of uh uh make the
entire Main Street all of the buildings
and and small businesses uh make sure
that they're sturdy and that they kind
of look nice they help employ thousands
of people of uh people in surrounding
areas they're bringing them into the
town even if only 2000 live there they
took over like an old plant that went
out of business and now they're using it
for all sorts of other businesses
they're
Etc and all I kept thinking about the
whole time I was watching this and maybe
I'm a weirdo for thinking this but I was
like the day this guy dies or sells his
business does that town fall apart yep
right and so you mentioned earlier kind
of treating your community well you're
an employer in the community all these
things
when you all come in sometimes the
management team stays sometimes you
bring in an external CEO or uh maybe the
seller is like hey I want to be the
advisor we need to bring in a new
management team
how do you balance like the success of
the business maybe because they're such
a good Steward of in the community and
they're such a great participant but
this new person coming in like maybe
they don't have a connection to the to
the town like like how do you think
about some of like the nitty-gritty
really weird details of these businesses
that don't fit in a spreadsheet yeah
well one there's there's a lot of magic
to these businesses where you start
picking them apart and you're going to
get some some really weird results which
is what I think your intuition is
pointing towards right like like let's
say that you know business has 50 major
decisions you can make about how you're
gonna where you're gonna place it and
how you're gonna run it and all these
things you don't know kind of which ones
you're you're pulling on when you start
making these changes which is why we are
for the most part pretty change diverse
right we want to make sure we fully
understand
um sort of the analogy I think in my
head is like you know a ball of yarn and
you start pulling on the thread and you
all you think all of a sudden you're
just pulling the thread then like half
the ball of yarn drops off the other
side right
same thing with the business right
enough stuff starts to break and all of
a sudden you get this weird compounding
in a bad way that occurs
um yeah we're we're very biased towards
keeping businesses in fact I want to
think of this we've never moved a
business I don't think you know we buy
businesses in small town America
um some are in large cities
but some of them are in small town
America and we love it we want them to
be there um we think that's a huge
Advantage for the business because
they're so deeply embedded there are
families that work at these businesses
right
um and to to get up and out it would
require a tremendous amount I mean I'm
not saying we would never do that but we
would think really long and hard about
it and and by the way we try to be part
of what does it mean to win right maybe
we could just kind of take a step back
and like all these decisions are kind of
put through the lens of in order to win
long term
everyone has to win
there's literally no way if you actually
think about the game theory of it for
anybody any one actor to win at the
expense of everyone long term in the
short term you can absolutely do that
right so this is kind of like the idea
of like one-time games very finite games
if you're playing a long game it's
really has to become an infinite game
and everyone around the table has to win
all this all the key stakeholders have
to win or it's not sustainable any one
of those key stakeholders drops out it's
not sustainable right so you think about
that and it really forces you to to put
yourself in the shoes of everyone around
you and say all right what are we going
to do that's going to help everyone win
over a long period of time and make sure
that they agree that that's the way they
want to win so I mean that's part of
what we do we get to know these
businesses we have these types of
conversations we try to talk to everyone
you know what are your goals what are
your aspirations what are you going to
be doing yeah how can we be a part of
that
we've talked a lot about maybe what I'll
call like peering into the business
right so they're running it you've got
the management teams Etc there
um Peter Lynch famously I think said if
you spent 15 minutes on macro you spend
13 minutes too long right
um and many people who uh will watch or
listen to this they're very interested
right now on what the Federal Reserve is
going to do or interest rates or
inflation and you know kind of name your
macro data point that they're paying
attention to
how much do you guys think about
business cycles and kind of external
things that are happening which may or
may not have an impact on a specific
business but seem to have a lot of
attention from the finance or business
world does that play into decisions that
you guys make you know interest rates on
debt don't really seem to make a a
difference because you don't take debt
so like how do you think about the
intersection of some of the businesses
you own and macro yeah what I would say
is we
um the macro is always going to affect
the micro but you we're not going to
make decisions based on macro we're
going to make them based on micro so
what I would say to you is especially
like 2021 was a good example of this
we saw a ton of business models that
um all of a sudden have these giant
spikes right
what happened
oh it's just the business model is great
and just just compounded it's like no it
was like you know very very level and
moderate growth and all of a sudden a
giant Spike and now you're trying to
sell the business based on you know two
times the earnings you experienced in
any previous year what could have caused
that
could have been coven you know they're
like oh no no it could have been covered
you know it's like of course no we sell
uh medical masks right definitely had
nothing to do with this nothing to do
with that right nothing to do at all I
mean honestly we saw a tremendous amount
now that can actually happen on both
directions right so you got to be able
to look at it and say it doesn't matter
what the past to the business is it
doesn't matter what's happened in the
past it's only helpful in being able to
predict the future and what we're trying
to do is we're trying to say okay look
from the time we buy it what do we think
without our involvement the trajectory
of the business is on and so we are very
interested in what major shocks in the
system what you know we're going to look
at different events let's say we looked
at the events industry and we looked at
the yeah personal protective equipment
industry right and we looked at that
same thing and we said okay what do we
think 2020 2021 is going to look like
for those two businesses do we think
there may be some abnormalities
associated with it so it's important you
get to know what the major macro events
are and kind of how it would affect
these different Industries so that when
you go into them and you're looking at
valuing them you certainly don't want to
overpay and you don't want to short
people when it's like obvious that okay
look there's a stumble because you know
you're throwing events or you were
supplying equipment to the event
industry or whatever it might be of
course there was like you know a year
where no one had an event so it's
important to think through it that way I
mean even even interest rates even
though they don't directly affect us
because typically we're not using debt
in our transactions our companies are
using lines of credit to grow the
business so it affects us there our
competitors are all using debt right so
when we think about like I mean there's
look there's a lot of times in 2021 that
we looked at each other and we said
how are we so off I mean we would be
outbid by 50 percent well when capital
is basically free right
you can bid some pretty crazy numbers
and make the spreadsheet work
um we thankfully never got there but it
was tempting at times
so as you're kind of looking at some of
those aspects of the macro environment
how much are you all pushing information
down to the companies right like I'm
assuming that you and your team are
better suited to evaluate macro than the
average small business owner in America
right they may pay attention to it they
probably read the news like all that
type of stuff but
we've talked a lot about things that you
guys could do change uh you know
incentives uh do branding help with like
online lead generation like there's very
tactical things but is there any element
of like you're just pushing information
down and I've seen you guys start to do
a lot more content online yeah some of
that seems to be aimed at you know hey
if you're a business owner you want to
sell your business here's kind of how we
operate and kind of inbound deal flow
but also it feels like man some of this
information that I've seen you guys post
I've listened to some of the episodes
Etc like this could be pretty valuable
actually for even the companies you
already own so how do you think about
kind of information that you all have
and getting it out to either future you
know sellers or even the companies
you've already bought yeah we think
about it a lot
um you know one we think that content's
the only way to scale conversation so
you know we want to have 10 000
conversations with Sellers and business
owners like there's no possible way we
can actually do that one-on-one so we
think that having conversations that we
can record things that we can write that
we can then share is a really helpful
thing
um in our portfolio we try to share
quite a bit I mean depends on the person
it depends on the cycle of the business
right if it's just heads down execution
we can share things here and there but
like actually very little is going to
adjust from a macro perspective is going
to adjust the micro now I can tell you
during covid when no one had any idea
where this was going to go I mean
example our pool business we thought for
sure that pool business was going to go
down a ton kind of say March April May
and I remember you know we were in touch
with that team a lot and and you know
it's like we'll start cutting prices
maybe we can pull some demand forward
maybe we can fill our pipeline to get
through you know we had no idea is this
pandemic gonna last three months is it
going to last
six months no no clue and then all of a
sudden the craziest thing happened which
was demand completely reversed and went
through the roof and was like
okay cut the price Cuts Like get get the
price cuts off and like how are we going
to then deal with inflation so it was
like okay the exact opposite problem so
there was a lot of information sharing
around okay what do we think other
businesses are doing in terms of price
increases how do we think about material
availability how do we think about Labor
availability you know we had this whole
issue where I mean the government
incentivized people not to work in in
the blue collar trades I mean we had
people come to us and and it's no fault
of their own they said look I can make
more money staying at home than working
what would you do if you were me um
he said Well we'd prefer you work but
you know totally understand if you if
you feel like it's not something you
want to do so there's a lot of these
macro headwinds and Tailwinds that you
got to kind of adjust to those do we are
in a better position than our portfolio
companies to kind of monitor that and
there's a feedback loop it's not just
one directional they're constantly
sending us stuff too and saying hey we
read this or we saw this or an industry
event that we were at they did this what
do you all think yeah one of the things
that as I invested in more and more
companies that portfolio got larger I
always struggled with was I didn't know
where the balance and kind of the right
way to do it when you buy a business
people probably want to talk to you
right like Brent I want to talk to him
he's he's the leader of the organization
that is buying my business
um you all are probably still at that
stage uh I would think maybe I'm wrong
uh Steve Schwartzman or Sam Zell or
whoever who's been doing it for you know
50 years they've probably escaped that
and now it's like hey if you know
blackstone's gonna come by your business
like not very many people are going to
demand to talk to you know whoever uh
they're probably just gonna say Hey you
know what's your offer who am I going to
be working with and kind of get the
deals done
but on the same side like the support of
the business is you have the same 24
hours as everybody else how do you think
about okay you want to kind of be the
leader that goes and you know shakes the
hand of the person you're buying the
business from but also you can't answer
every single phone call or email like
how do you scale yourself like how have
you at least thought about this and then
also from an organization standpoint is
there like a threshold that you kind of
cross into whether it's size of team or
number of businesses or something where
you go look we got to now have you know
a portfolio manager and like they're
your point of contact how have you
handle handle this yeah we've actually
already crossed this okay amazing yeah
so even better because now you can tell
me how you did it yeah this is this was
this was actually it was a big change I
mean I remember getting the point where
there was no way that I could go on
every site to visit have every phone
call I mean this is probably four or
five years ago
um and so now I mean the goal of any
business I think is to replace yourself
with people who are more talented than
you are you know we have a little bit
something different about our model and
this maybe kind of goes to to something
a little bit Zoom doubt then even with
the question you asked which is how you
scale a normal private Equity Firm is
you hire more Partners so partners are
what I call like private Equity firms in
a box right so you hire another partner
to find more deals to be able to
negotiate more deals to do diligence on
more deals to negotiate the paperwork on
the deals and then to ultimately operate
them sit on the board of directors post
close right so if you and I owned a
private Equity Firm together and we said
okay we're kind of maxed out like how do
we grow well we got to find a third
partner and then we got to find a fourth
partner and then we gotta find a fifth
partner this is the same thing like how
law firms grow or accounting firms grow
um so that's the traditional way of
doing it that's how almost everyone else
does it I don't come from a finance
background right we haven't really
talked about this you know I've joked in
the past I'm like the Forrest Gump of
private Equity right
um I kind of fell backwards into this
and so I I don't have any of the muscle
memory of how a private Equity Firm
should be built so I looked at it and
said well why in the world would you do
it that way it seems really hard to find
people who can do all these things
exceptionally well these are all these
jobs that I just described they're very
difficult jobs they're very different
skill sets what I said was why would we
run this like a manufacturing operation
right you wouldn't expect the welder to
do all the woodwork right like that
doesn't make any sense you say hey we
want to go out and hire the guy who's
amazing at welding and we're going to
hire the guy who can do carving right
those are very different skill sets same
thing in our business how you talk to a
seller or a leadership team when you
first get in touch with the business
what you ask how you ask it how you
pursue it what you push on what you
don't is completely different skill set
than how you operate the business post
close now you want a continuity of
information you want to make sure
there's not disincentives or wrong
incentives along the way to pass the
buck that something's bad right but we
have specialists in each area so we have
Partners those partners are over a
specific vertical right so somebody
who's only over the intake of the
business once that once that business
gets to a letter of intent they fall off
we have a new team that comes in so
we're kind constantly moving them
between these things which makes it
really much easier for me so instead of
being the partner that's in charge of
leading a deal we actually don't have a
partner that's in charge of leading a
deal right we have a whole team of
people that comes around your business
everyone it's kind of like uh I don't
know it's like the the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen or the X-Men or
something that's right like like you
don't want Cyclops to go underwater
right it's not going to be a healthy
thing right we got each person's got
their own powers that they are really
really good at and what we try to say is
hey here's the kind of array of people
around you at any given stage you're
going to know who's kind of the lead
person but that lead person is going to
change depending on the stage we're in
and then how once you've bought the
business is it the same thing where uh
you basically use that manufacturing
analogy now all of a sudden you're the
owner you have somebody who hey they're
gonna help you with marketing if you
need help they're going to help you with
Finance whatever and there's not really
one single point of contact that's
supposed to oversee everything yeah so
we actually have two points of contact
UM that help resource the company beyond
that so we have an operating partner and
we have a financial partner they're
creating feedback loops in those
companies so the financial partners
interacting with their financial team
creating financial reporting reviewing
things uh providing feedback Trend
spotting all these different things
you'd want them to do then the operating
partner is really becoming the advisor
kind of the more of the board of
directors in a box if you want to call
it that for the company and then their
job is then between the two of them to
Resource the company besides kind of the
things that they directly offer right so
it depends on the person the operating
partner they're gonna have different
skill sets but let's say that um they
want to recruit an executive right
they're going to say hey let's get Kelly
involved here's how Kelly Works what do
you think yeah great let's get Kelly
involved then Kelly who's our lead
person on recruiting she comes in and
helps someone's recruiting it's a very
specific talent that she's adding to
that so their job is to kind of
understand the strategy do the
governance uh oversee the companies uh
develop relationships succession
planning all those things and then
resource the company either from within
or without
you've been doing this now for 15 years
13 years 15 years 15 years ago so 15
years uh you are not old which is uh
unique well here's why you because I
haven't been called not old in a long
time so that's good well I was recently
reading something and uh I don't
remember the exact age but I believe
that uh Bernard I know who lvmh yeah
um I think that he finally got control
right around
39 or 41 somewhere somewhere in that
range no
which many people when I was 21 I was
like oh that's real old right now I'm
like hey chill chill out that's right
exactly but
he then went on a 30-year done and when
you think of doing something and doing
it well and being obsessed and focused
with it for 30 years you can accomplish
some pretty incredible things
when you think about what's ahead of you
is it just more of the same or is it hey
we want these businesses to grow in size
and use the free cash flow to buy more
business like how do you think about
what's like the the next 30-year plan
and you may tell me actually in five
years I'm gonna retire and never talk to
anyone again but like how do you think
about the next like 30 years yeah well I
recently turned 40 so it's been a uh I
wasn't gonna say that I was gonna let
people think that you were somewhere
between 25 and 55 yeah yeah yeah yeah
well I feel like it's to to put a flag
in the ground and I mean Bezos didn't
start Amazon until he was at 39.40 uh I
think somewhere I think in like mid 30s
but yeah is it mid 30s okay maybe it's a
little bit younger than that but uh yeah
so it means it's inspired is the new 35.
it's a 40 is the new 35. yeah 40s the
new 20. no is that no that's probably
not the case um yeah so in terms of the
plan like I didn't have a plan for
permanent Equity 15 years ago
um I had none of the stuff that we're
doing now was on the radar even five
years ago if you if you kind of go back
we had just raised our first Fund in
fact we were actually in the throes of
raising the first fund weren't sure if
we're going to be able to convert over
or not I mean it was a it was a
stressful time right and it's gone way
better than I ever could have imagined
and so I feel like the
um
I am I'm always interested in thinking
ahead of what what could come next
um you know a a clear path is to
continue to raise Capital to continue to
serve our customers well it seems like
everything everyone's happy in the
system it seems like when we created
kind of a de novo new way to do private
Equity
um which you know everyone does it one
way and you do it something other way it
probably shouldn't work turns out it's I
think working decently well I think the
model I'd prefer our model to any other
model right
um so I think it's got legs to be able
to continue growing in the future we get
continually pulled into larger and
larger opportunities you know ironically
our model works better even up Market
from where it is today
um
but at the end of the day I have no idea
where this one's gonna go and I think
always planning and never having a plan
is kind of like the ultimate uh
combination so
um I think our model Works in other
geographies uh worldwide I mean I think
there's a real opportunity probably in
Germany and uh in England
um Canada we really not touched much
Australia New Zealand Japan's Got a
really interesting economy for for
something similar to what we're doing
obviously there's a lot of cultural
nuances to moving into those
um there's a lot of baggage that comes
with moving up Market because that's
what every other private Equity Firm uh
has done
um and really what we've just tried to
do is to say we're going to do it make
sense we're going to try to treat
everyone exceptionally well so we always
want our investors to know that like
whatever we do we're gonna have their
back and the employees at these
companies whatever we do they're going
to have their back so
um I feel like we can't lose you know
and tomorrow's not assured so I have no
idea I'm uh trying to take it day by day
everything you've done is in the private
markets you talked about geography and
industries would you guys ever look at
public opportunities to bring private or
take a permanent Equity public like how
do you think about public versus private
marketing yeah that's a great question
we have looked at a couple take privates
um ultimately we just don't have good
muscle memory for it there's just a
whole other set of rules I mean we're
highly regulated now we've come to a big
enough size from a capital perspective
where we're I mean we're regulated like
the big boys are right and um
um that is its own Challenge and its own
barrier uh in some ways it's costly uh
and kind of stressful to deal with
regulation
um but you know I think we're doing
great in that department when you get
into the public markets kind of a
different level of scrutiny and a
different level of of rules and what you
can and can't do
um I actually uh looked at a uh uh I
take private at one point this is way in
the past and I just didn't know what I
was doing so I went and met with the CEO
and I you know I was kind of getting uh
excited about the opportunity and and
you know he he kind of made it clear
that he was like I'm doing this out of a
favor to a friend like I'm I'm not
meeting with you because I'm interested
in you know your firm helping us at all
and I was like okay well you know great
to meet you or whatever and he made like
two or three comments I was like man
that seems like oddly specific
information he goes oh by the way son I
just want to let you know you're now uh
opted out of being able to do anything
in the public markets because that's not
uh public information I just gave to you
and I was like wait what and he was like
so if you were thinking about buying our
stock you can't buy it now
I was like shoot you know so like
there's just a whole lot of different
set of rules that you have to go on and
also it feels like uh you know if you're
the Newbie sitting down to the poker
table and you're playing with shark
correct they uh they know exactly what
information to tell you correct yeah so
I would say not not say that we wouldn't
ever go do it it's just an expertise
that we haven't built up and uh you know
never say never but you know we're not
sure in terms of taking something public
I mean I think the one thing that is
frustrating to me
um there's always opportunity cost to
everything you know we would love to be
able to help
[Music]
our employees compound their capital
with us right because the way the rules
are set up in the United States around
um being a qualified investor and all
these things like we can't take
investment from hardly anybody right
there's a very narrow group of people we
can take investment from and I
understand why the rules are there and
we can debate the merits of that totally
get it um it would it would be
interesting at some point to be able to
offer the opportunity to work with us to
a larger group of people but we have no
plans for that yeah um so it's um
interesting the name is permanent equity
there are many vehicles that somehow I
figured out how to get truly permanent
Equity with no uh kind of end life of
the fund right when uh in the Bitcoin
World there is a uh a fund that is run
by grayscale who's got about three and a
half percent of all uh I think of the
supply uh circulating when the Bitcoin
went in or the dollars went in they're
not coming back out yeah and so there's
this permanent Equity component but to
your point there's a hell of a lot of
rules and also uh the day-to-day
scrutiny right you know I'm assuming you
guys aren't sitting there trying to
figure out are you up you know uh this
multiple or that multiple on a
day-to-day basis yeah we don't have to
worry about day to day with the uh with
the stock market a little bit different
yeah for sure yeah
um I asked people for questions and so
uh I I held off I was gonna email and
text a bunch of our mutual friends and I
was like nah I'm not gonna subject him
to that and I have a couple sure the
first Morgan hausel yeah you you and him
that guy sucks
you and him don't get along on the
internet but I know you guys are good
friends
he has no clue I'm going to ask you this
but at what point did uh the razzing of
Morgan begin he's just he's the he's my
uh he's my fake fake Twitter Nemesis um
yeah yeah Morgan uh Morgan's such a
great friend he's a great guy we were
actually texting back and forth
yesterday it's hilarious um yeah people
people who I just started going after
him just because he's such a like he's
such a lovable guy and he's so humble
and and it's just hilarious to make fun
of he's just like the guy that you're
with like you know at a sports game that
you just keep harassing on him right and
he just takes it and do people think
fire serious people thought I was
serious like I had multiple people I've
read reach out and be like hey man I
don't think it's worth it like you you
know can you just like can you tone it
down a little bit like hey what do you
have against Morgan like what I'm like
no no you don't understand it's it must
be the the the worst kept inside joke
yeah but yeah he uh he and I are great
friends and uh I admire the heck out of
him he's a great dude every time I see
one of you say something it crap I don't
know why but it just crashed me up I'm
like what do these two guys and I and
I've always thought like I'm sure people
think they're serious right so that's
pretty good
um Twitter in general is something that
you've used sometimes you're using a lot
sometimes you're not how do you think
about uh not just the firm communicating
but you communicating
um through whether it's social media or
you guys wrote a book right and so that
was the whole process like talk a little
bit about your communication with not
only business owners but maybe like
broader business and investing Community
yeah I mean I think
um over time does Twitter's just become
a source of fun and enjoyment for me and
something that I enjoy trying to help
people through
um you know I at one time you know it's
like try to be a thought leader try to
put out interesting content try to do
whatever when I stop doing all that
garbage and just focused on like trying
to help people and put out things that I
thought were interesting and
um again content's the only way to
attract the right people and repel the
wrong people so you know every time you
say something into the world especially
when you've got a megaphone like a
Twitter can provide you're going to lose
a bunch of people and you're going to
gain a bunch of people and the people
you lose or people who don't agree with
you or don't want what you're saying and
the people you gain are more in your
tribe right and so
um you know I've enjoyed it from that
perspective I mean I met most of my good
friends through Twitter I mean my life
would not be nearly the same if it
wasn't for Twitter I'd used to joke that
I monetize Twitter better than Twitter
has may still hold
um and really I would just you know from
like an encouragement perspective we
encourage people just be who they really
are I feel like that social media
creates this inauthenticity that you
want to put up a you know mask on and
say I want to present myself a certain
way and my life a certain way and
um it may work for a little while but
people can tell and when that gets
shattered I think people people don't
care for it I mean I'm curious about you
I mean you've got a huge Twitter
following I knew you before you hadn't
love hate uh relationship yeah yeah I
mean I knew you before you had any
Twitter following uh I think that you
had more Twitter followers than me for
sure I didn't did you even have a
Twitter account when I first met you I
think I had one but I hadn't used you
had like a hundred you had like 100
followers or something yeah yeah so yeah
how's it been for you I mean what's the
question is I think your point about
like monetizing it better than Twitter
has uh I could sit here and rattle off a
bunch of probably friends that I have
and mutual friends that we have that
they've built their business they've
literally started companies of people
they met on Twitter they've got
investors that way they've raised
Capital all these different things which
is amazing from a business perspective I
find the most valuable part is not so
much
um I think a lot about in life is like
there's three groups of people that you
can aspire to or or spend your time with
which is like there's your Heroes your
peers and then like the Next Generation
sure and I actually see most people on
Twitter they're trying to get in touch
with their heroes or they're trying to
engage with them or enter those
conversations and if I'm honest with
myself I actually think outside of maybe
guests for the podcast because a lot of
that has happened where I've just DM
someone they like responded me or
something and kind of opened the door
um and you shoot your shot I've actually
probably met the most younger people yep
and that to me is a place where like I
you know I've thought like I don't know
how I would have met those people
otherwise the peers you meet you know
and just kind of doing deals or talking
to people or whatever the heroes you can
read about see them do interviews like
all that kind of stuff but it's actually
like the younger people uh again I'm
getting to an age where like I'm
probably disconnected to some degree and
so I meet these people and it always
cracks me up because I can tell oh
you're from a different generation
they'll hit me with like uh we have one
person who works with now I met on
Twitter
and he'll send me these text messages
it's like deciphering a new you know a
secret code yeah I can't do it the first
time you hit me with the letter P good
I was like pretty good okay I got like
hey you know oh that's good I was
actually like trying through it myself
right and he like kept sending these
text messages and I was just like man I
need to find more young people because
like I hope that we're not putting this
in you know like actual professional
communication yeah like this is a whole
different culture this is a whole
different way they talk about whatever
and one of the things that I started to
realize was like these young people were
taking tick tocks that were being
uploaded and they were putting them on
Twitter and so I'm not on Tick Tock but
like I almost felt like I was getting
you know a flavor of like oh that's
what's going on there because I'm saving
content here so I think there's one the
other piece of it is in whether better
or worse like it is that megaphone I
think you said it earlier like content
is the way you scale conversation I've
never heard anyone describe it that way
Twitter to me is maybe one of the best
ways to do that because yes a podcast or
a YouTube writing you can reach a really
deep connection yep but man if you get a
tweet that you know takes off it's
really hard to write something that
reaches a million people right it's hard
to get a podcast with a million
listeners and Nuance is hard too yeah of
course and and so I I look at Twitter a
lot actually as like there's this output
but maybe the response is more valuable
yeah and you put things out there all
the time and you're like oh I am an
idiot thank you for reminding me like I
didn't think about this or that or
whatever so I don't know no I mean I I
have a love hate and I think that the
love is I love chatting with people and
getting to know new people and it's been
a great Serendipity engine right if you
want to think about that way
um the hate is just that uh when I'm at
my worst it's like a really bad
reinforcement of all the things I should
not want from the world right it's like
oh well I don't feel loved I don't have
attention so I need to go and get
attention online right like that's a
it's a very toxic uh cycle you can get
yourself into so as someone who went
through uh uh this
um I now can see it playing out and I've
sent messages to people privately said
hey you're not gonna listen to me right
because guess what somebody said it to
me and I didn't listen to them but on
the rise up just remember there's
another side to the hill and
that can be a forced error I could be an
unforced error that can be a mainstream
media thing or that literally can just
be like hey you're you know you're the
darling today because your company is
doing well yeah covet happens right yeah
you know that big event business you had
nobody anymore so I think that's
interesting another person that I was
going to message uh but did not because
I knew for sure he definitely was going
to give me too much dirt Patrick
O'Shaughnessy yeah uh I think I've heard
you guys talk about you talk multiple
times a week for sure yeah I think maybe
even multiple times all right
um he has built a whole kind of media
Empire of himself he's got his Venture
fund uh you all appear on the outside to
come from completely different
approaches to investing Capital but
you're great friends talk a little bit
about whether it's him or other people
like that that you spend time talking
with but they now actually do exactly
what you do in terms of deploying
Capital well those are my favorite
people I mean I honestly I I don't have
uh great contacts relationships
um with other private Equity people
um one I think just because what we do
and how we do it is so weird and
different than traditional private
Equity
um I think in some ways we're kind of
like the zoo animal in the private
Equity World
um but yeah Patrick in particular he we
got we met online met on Twitter he had
actually uh put out a tweet he was like
talking about Capital allocation he's
like hey can somebody talk to me who
does Capital allocation for a living and
I was thinking to myself well I allocate
Capital like I don't know I'll reach out
and I'll say hey sounds great so we got
on the phone this is two thousand 14
probably
2015. it's been a long time and
um we got about three minutes into the
conversation he's like wait stop what do
you do
and I said well you know we buy these
small companies like how much do you pay
for them I was like well you know we pay
like four or five times free cash flows
like and these aren't like going
bankrupt I said no no there's
small companies you know they're hard to
get access to hard to run everything's
hard about them he's like all right stop
I don't want to talk about I thought we
were going to talk about like Capital
location to public markets like I don't
talk about that at all like tell me more
about what you do so fire away whatever
questions we asked me like 30 I mean
incredible questions Patrick's always
been he's got a mind for interviewing
and uh now the whole world can can see
it um I still remember when he was like
Hey I'm thinking about starting a
podcast and I was like oh that's
interesting like well
wonderful alternative anything you know
turns out it has
um
but anyway so he's we chatted and then
he was like hey can I come visit you
sure I loved having guests you've been
in Columbia Missouri Patrick came to
Columbia Missouri I was going to ask
about the Columbia Missouri pilma Bridge
uh because I uh when I tweeted and asked
people for questions literally I think
two different people I went and I had a
steak with Brent in Missouri Columbia
Missouri yeah I love having I love uh
hosting people in Columbia so anyway so
he came to Missouri and I mean I don't
know it's just you you jive with certain
people and he's just he and I've always
just been like Kindred Spirits since the
very beginning he came in we talked for
like 13 straight hours one day and at
the end of it he was like okay look like
I want my family to invest and I was
like sorry to break it to you like we
don't take outside capital and I
remember when you came and visited me in
Columbia this is again seven years ago
one time ago six and a half years ago
seven years ago
um I probably said to you like we'll
probably never take outside Capital
because I really believed at that time
because I thought my choices were either
taking a traditional private Equity
structure so two and twenty you know fee
structure with a 10-year time Horizon
which would have completely destroyed
our business model yep would not have
given us the right incentives
um it was just a non-starter or create a
hold code which has lots of challenges
with how you raise more Capital there's
you know you get to Value the assets uh
initially if you've already got
something started which we had at the
time and so I just really felt like
neither of them were going to be the
thing and we were doing just fine like
we were making really good money and
compounding and
um I felt comfortable that we didn't
need to raise outside capital and I met
Patrick and he blew up my life and uh in
in all the best ways
um but he also didn't take no for an
answer he didn't take no for an answer
so what he said was he's like
tell me what it would take
and I was like what do you mean tell me
like he's like I said we're not gonna do
it he's like no no like you create a
structure
you tell me all the rules of the
structure what do you want how do the
fees work everything like that just make
it work for you and then I'll tell you
if my family can do it or not
I thought well that's a challenge I get
to create a completely new system okay
and really he enabled that creativity I
mean without Patrick I wouldn't have had
the creativity to do this and um
anyway so I got in front of a whiteboard
for multiple days and basically sketched
out what we have now and presented it to
him and um
he took it to his dad and they talked
about it and he came back and said a
little tweak here a little tweak there
and we're ready to go and I said what
was the structure it's the same
structure we have today I mean honestly
it's uh so no fees of any kind no
reimbursements any kind uh so we only
get paid whenever we start returning
cash back to the investors they get a
hurdle then we get a catch up and then
we split above that
um typically no debt nor transactions uh
and uh I asked for 50 years on a Time
Horizon and actually got 50 years and
then uh another family that got involved
later their their lead attorney said I
would never let the family agree to 50
years that's insane like no one no one
gets to keep capital for 50 years
and I said okay what's the longest
structure you've ever seen because I
could tell he was serious about this he
was like look son you know it was like
one of those like yeah this isn't Gonna
Fly and we're serious we're serious
right I mean he was a serious man like
they were a serious family he's a
serious man and uh and he said I okay
look one time I saw 27 years with three
one-year extensions and I was like sold
that was it that was it so anyway that's
the structure we have and that's the
structure we have for the first fund for
the second fund has worked out great
um I got cold feet I think twice during
that process of raising that initial fun
so so Patrick's family says yes we want
to we want to invest and I said great
like now what and he said well we know a
bunch of rich people it's like great who
knew you know
um so he started making introductions
and I mean literally like his team to
his credit like he's like send me your
numbers well we actually create a deck
for you like like they did a lot of work
and uh we're just incredible partners he
and his father Jim are just both of them
gems of human beings and um multiple
times through the process though I was
like I'm giving up I don't know what I'm
going into it's like I was exiting a
phase of my life in my career where you
know I had kind of made it right I like
we had we had a great team we were on a
great trajectory the businesses were
working the strategy was working and we
were kind of breaking the thing that was
working to make something new it was
scary and there was you know not
everyone in my office was uh in
agreement that that's the direction we
wanted to go there are a lot of heated
discussions
um around what we were going to do and
multiple times I called them and I was
like I just don't think this is worth it
and he's like stop being an idiot this
is worth it here's how it's gonna work
you're fine like you know kind of stay
the course type thing
literally like talk me off the ledge
twice and so I mean truly the there
wouldn't be a any outside Capital there
wouldn't be a first fund there would be
a second fund without without Patrick
and his dad and uh then we just
developed a friendship we created this
event called Capital Camp which is it's
kind of crazy how the thing I mean we
just thought we'd get some friends
together in Missouri and show them a
really great time the joke is that I run
a Food and Wine Festival and Patrick
runs an investing conference right
um
it's turned into this like really big
International Event like last year we
had 400 people from 16 countries
um a lot of capital in the room and just
try to make this experience it's in
Columbia Missouri right nothing cracks
me up more than like people flying in
not only just from like New York L.A San
Francisco Dallas you know into Colombia
people were flying from like Shanghai
and Singapore and South Africa and
Switzerland to like Columbia Missouri so
just have fun
when you guys set up the structure yep
uh
uh a family or a private investor had a
lot of flexibility you also have
institutions yes that have invested what
was that conversation like
well a lot of Institutions said uh just
left us out of the room to be completely
honest especially on the I mean the the
last fundraise I mean we were we had we
had raised one uh One Fund but it was
pretty small
um the initial fund was 50 million we
were raising 300 this last time and um
you know they kind of counted that as
like the First Institutional raise so
that kind of counts as you're really
your first Fund in their eyes and a lot
of them are just like look we don't do
first funds which
I get it kind of to some degree but like
if you're gonna wait until somebody's
already like proven themselves like
haven't you missed the like the real
early opportunity to get with them and
become like a true partner so but anyway
there were a bunch of people and also
first time funds usually outperform
first to find funds do outperform
um now there's also a lot of people who
shouldn't raise capital and and all
these last first time funds that also
don't perform at all correct yes so we
should you know in all caveats or maybe
some survivorship bias yeah
um but uh but anyway so um yeah I mean a
lot of people left us out of the room I
mean we had a lot of people who said one
you're not gonna be able to build this
in Columbia Missouri like who the heck
would ever live in Columbia Missouri and
we're like like your what we do and we
think it's pretty awesome
um
and another one was just like building
any firm new is really really hard
um and I said well yeah but we've been
doing this for like a decade already so
you got to remember like we didn't just
like come up with an idea and say hey
we're gonna raise money to do this like
we did it with our own capital for like
the better part of a decade and you know
the actually the the ability to go slow
this is what you know I I have probably
two or three people a month who reach
out to me and say Hey I want to do what
you do
um on the surface the returns look
fantastic right the math is not hard if
you're if you're buying something at a
four or five times multiple in free cash
flow you're starting with a 25 20 yield
on that Capital right and you can grow
the business the returns are Incredible
without any debt right like that's just
the Baseline assumptions so people look
at that and say well that's better than
I can get anywhere else like I should go
move into this I always tell people it's
simple like there are no secrets like
I'm happy to answer any question that
anybody has it's just really hard and
judgment really matters
if you'd given me 50 million dollars two
years into what we were doing I would
have lost all the money
if you'd given me 300 million dollars in
five years I would have lost all the
money it's just takes a long time to
hone you have to look at thousands and
thousands of deals to hone what do you
like what do you not like how you know
how do you see these things play out
over time
and if you're given a lot of capital you
can just short-circuit a lot of that
learning and you can pretend to be good
for a while and you just got to get
lucky and hope that it all works out and
um
I gotta tell you I'm I uh I've seen a
lot of people come and go
um there's almost no one who's actually
been able to start and build with some
some exceptions which have been
fantastic I mean we always try to help
anybody who wants to enter the industry
we actually try to be helpful to them
which sounds like a weird like aren't
they quote unquote competitors to what
we're doing the Market's enormous there
are just an ocean of people out there
who need to sell their business and
there's not enough qualified people
there's enough people who like sure you
and give me your business but like I
don't have qualified people who really
can take that business and move it
forward and so
um I actually think it's a great
opportunity if you're listening to this
and you want to get into the space I
would encourage you to try to get into
the space
um just take it slow like really learn
what you're doing uh and it's mostly
learn about people the people I think
that that have the worst time
and have the most access are like the
finance types the people who look just
graduated from Yale Stanford Harvard
wherever big MBA program
um you know they know a bunch of people
with a bunch of capital they can raise
the money they've never operated
anything or if they have they've been at
like a big company or in sort of a
bigger organization as like a low tier
or middle manager right
that training just isn't that valuable
um
two running owning and running a small
business and also you know the way in
which the deal process works and
operations post close are really
disconnected in terms of value so if
you're really really good at finding
opportunities and selling investors on
how to invest and all this stuff like
you're probably almost by Nature not
going to be good at the post-close
operation so there's all these like
stumbling blocks along the way the path
looks so easy
just find a business that's making two
three five million dollars pay four
fives maybe six times for it God forbid
and uh then you grow the business and
you exit a period later and you make
millions and millions of dollars and
retire like duh just do it right like of
course it's easy it actually is that
simple it's just the stumbling blocks of
doing it are tremendous and so
um that's been something that's
interesting over time to watch a lot of
people that are frankly way more
intelligent way more educated
um way harder workers I think than we
are
um that have been able to do it because
they've actually Gone Too Fast Too
Quickly somebody once told me that
operating a business is like looking at
uh a beach full of sand and when you
start walking you have to try to figure
out where is actual sand versus
quicksand because it all looks the same
and if you can just you know go down the
entire Beach and avoid all the quicksand
then you'll be fine but uh good luck
yeah I've I've equated it to um being in
a constant Knife Fight where you you
just get out of bed in the morning and
try not to get knifed that day and then
get back into bed and do it all over the
next day I mean it's amazing like you
know people look at successful business
owners and and look you you can make
millions and millions of dollars right
have this incredible free cash flow
engine that you can build over time like
it's very attractive if you make it the
number of things that can happen to a
business and the number of things that I
have seen in my career that just make no
sense that you just be blown away by
it's extraordinary right I mean we've
put so many people through rehab we've
had people who've done all kinds of
crazy stuff have embezzled money we've
had I mean you get weird stuff in the
mail from the government you're like
well that law conflicts with this other
law which law do you want me to follow
that's not our problem
either way you're screwed right like you
cannot do everything well and so that's
where you just have to get into
businesses where there's margin of
safety you can't use as much debt I mean
you know we haven't really talked about
the philosophy behind debt but that's
another thing was like we try to be
humble in not only our approach but also
in the price we pay and the fact that we
don't use debt because we're trying to
set up these situations to be the most
durable they possibly can because
frankly
these small businesses are outrageously
volatile without adding any more
volatility to the situation
what I think a lot about is maybe in the
more traditional tech industry it's
always how high does it go you're in a
power law game right and so it's
literally uh you're basically buying
these lottery tickets to a degree and
now you try to if you're a good investor
pick the ones have higher probability
maybe things that you could help uh find
the right Founders like all the things
that make you know the good Lottery
Pickers good but you're still playing a
power log game and so it's all about
height and and velocity and growth rate
and all those things
you're playing a game of like how bad
can it go yep right because you're
actually buying something you're paying
based on how it's already going and if
it degrades you lose money you lose a
lot of money right very quickly yeah and
and what I always think about is like I
guess in both scenarios there's a 1x
downside the difference though is that
when you're playing the power law game
the rest of the portfolio can like
easily make up for any losses you
actually go into it thinking you're
gonna lose 50 to 80 of the time yep when
you're playing a game of buying cash
flowing businesses
you're not uh hoping that you lose one
percent of the time you're hoping
actually that everything is you know
flat to up correct and so you have you
know a a very different kind of
calculation because you don't have that
power law yep and so debt obviously
becomes a whole different game uh and
it's understandable why people use it of
course but at the same time some
business models can handle a lot of debt
right I mean the predictability of the
outcome really is is indicative of the
amount of debt you can use most small
businesses are highly unpredictable so
if you're running a business that has an
incredible base of recurring Revenue
that's like you know let's say that
hypothetically you could get a stream of
income that we knew exactly how much
money we were going to make for the next
10 years
like like no questions asked backed by
the US government let's say it's a
government contract or something that's
locked in for 10 years guaranteed
there's no outs the government's going
to pay you for whatever your service or
product you're doing for the next 10
years
look you can you can definitely put debt
on that business because you have high
predictability of outcomes right now do
you want to try to grow beyond that if
you lever it up there's no Capital to
reinvest in the business so you can
still get yourself into trouble even
when things are predictable right
if you've got a business that's like
what I call a normal small business
that's going to go up and go down and
you're going to have people leave and
you're going to have all kinds of weird
headwinds and Tailwinds and Crosswinds
and all this stuff like putting debt on
a business only helps one of the people
at the table and that's the investor
everyone else loses
you're the only one who wins now in the
short term if you're going to play the
short run
you can win at the expense of everyone
else and that's what traditional private
Equity historically has done I want to
paint the entire industry's app because
there's some awesome people they're very
very thoughtful and great stewards that
are in private Equity that have a
traditional model
but traditionally if you look at most of
of the industry the leveraged buyout
industry in particular it has been how
do we lever this thing with Max debt so
we can put in minimal Equity so that
this thing works heads I win tells you
loose and the Tails by the way you being
not only the debt holders but also the
employees and the executive teams and
the communities they're in the suppliers
the customers everyone else loses at the
expense of the investor
that doesn't seem like a game I want to
play
um we want to play again where everyone
wins long term and we think that the
actual volatility of these businesses
where everyone else says that's a
weakness right because we had a lot of
investors you know go back to your
question about uh what did institutional
investors say they were like you know I
just don't think you can buy these
highly volatile small businesses at
scale and make money doing it we're like
okay that's a BET right what they're
saying is we don't think you can do it
and to be honest and the outside looking
in I think that's actually a pretty
reasonable thing to say when you get
close and you say well what if instead
of the volatility being a bad thing
because volatility goes both directions
correct it goes up and goes down
if you don't use any debt and you can
handle High volatility then like our
Aerospace business yeah High volatility
down now there's gonna be high
volatility back up what if you can use
that cash flow to reinvest back in the
business and catch that volatility on
the way up when no one else can you
sound like a Bitcoin investor there you
go well I don't know about that that's a
whole for me no but but it is true right
like I think that this idea of the
volatility but really what you're
talking about is like if you're durable
as a business owner because of the way
that you bought the business it goes
back to and it's so funny because I
think a lot of times when I talk to
people who are doing something that
appears to be new it really goes back to
the topless investing principles like
you make the money on the purchase yeah
right and so purchase could be the price
but also could be the structure in which
you choose to do it all right so you
guys figure that out price and structure
matters absolutely last thing I want to
talk to you about uh the number one
question I got was your uh kind of
Journey in faith oh yeah a believer in
Jesus
um I don't know when uh you kind of
inverted but my understanding is you're
an atheist yeah now you're not yeah
tell kind of that Journey what happened
yeah and what I found so fascinating is
uh not only the level of interest when I
ask for questions but also it was people
who obviously didn't know who you were
yeah they had never seen you on the
internet or anything and so one of the
people that already said I went to his
bio and I saw this and asked him about
it yeah and I was like wow maybe it's
something that's not Brent specific as
much as it is uh there's this um maybe
human uh curiosity sure so talk a little
bit about that Journey yeah man um it
has been it's been incredible I um
let's see here so I told my mom I didn't
believe in God when I was saying nine
I've always just been a hot star tough
kid I was I was coming hot coming in hot
um yeah I uh I I actually asked my mom
to drive me to the church when I was 14
uh because I set up a meeting
unbeknownst to my parents with the head
pastor at a local church and I was like
hey can you drive me to this church and
she was like do you use anything you
want to tell me like
is there drug issue is somebody pregnant
you know like what's going on I'm like
no no I just have all these questions
about faith and uh met with pastors
unbelievable guy uh super thoughtful
kind generous sat with me for probably
over an hour and I just pounded him with
question after question I just could not
understand what was going on
and I just said after that I was like I
couldn't get the answers I wanted my my
heart was hardened at that point and I
just I was done with it so from like you
know kind of 14 15
through my
gosh mid to late 20s
um I was just an atheist like I I was a
what I would call strict materialist you
know this world is what it is it's what
we can see and touch there's nothing
Beyond this and
um
that was it right in fact I made fun of
Christians I was like come on guys like
the Big Sky Fairy come on like what what
is all that going on come on here like
let's not let's not go through all that
garbage right
um I thought Christians were dumb I
thought they were uneducated I thought
they they didn't know what they were
doing and um I reached a point in my
career uh where
um was making more money than I ever
thought I would make and I had married a
beautiful woman who loved me and
everything was just Gray
it was dark
um
I didn't really care I didn't care about
life I told my wife I didn't love her
um I didn't care about anything food
didn't taste good best drinks didn't
taste good it just kind of was all gray
I was like this is it like you make
money and then you buy stuff with it and
then you just kind of then then you die
someday and
ultimately you're in the Dustbin of
History like that's it that's the world
it's just like this this real nihilism
that had set in for me she's like
nothing mattered right and and
intellectually I just couldn't get to a
spot where I could figure out like what
is morality
like if there's no ultimate Authority
then there is no objective morality like
you can say I believe in this and I
believe in that but like so what like I
believe in something different there's
no ultimate arbiter
and so you know everything again just
the beauty of everything kind of
dissipated as I the more I got into this
and um the only thing that would you
know help me was just not to think about
it then I was like man do I really want
to live a life that's unexamined like is
the only way to live life in a way that
I really don't explore the deepest
questions that there are out there
and right around that time
um I look at now as God calling me
started putting Christians in my life
who were like way more educated than me
and they started really challenging me
on like you say that do you actually
know what that means have you read this
have you thought about this have you
done this and I was like
oh shoot I thought I was pretty well
educated and I I don't know and so I
started just reading books and I went
from like God being an impossibility I
mean when I started my heart was so hard
I was like there's no way
and look I had all the things like I had
all the the worldly things that you
could want right my life from the
outside looking in was great like I
didn't need God like I didn't care right
but there was just this deep longing
right um C.S Lewis was a major influence
on me as I as I came to Faith he's got
these great quotes about like you know
we yearn for food there's for there's
something called food right we yearn for
sex there's something there's sex right
um the things that we yearn for are
reality and so we all yearn for meaning
which means there is deeper meaning like
the animals they don't yearn for deeper
meaning we do right there's a difference
and so I started reading and and slowly
over time like it went from an
impossibility to like oh shoot there's a
lot of people who are deeply thoughtful
and study this stuff to plausible and
then it really just centered around the
resurrection of Jesus
um
you know so Christianity just to take a
step back um it's lumped in with all the
other religions
um I actually was uh I did quite a bit
of religious studies in undergrad as an
atheist and um you know I would say
maybe to Define religion here is is
there's a set of rules so some some
higher power gives a set of rules about
how the world works that some are unseen
but if you do enough of these rules you
get favor in this life in the next right
would you would you I think I could say
that was a fair Affair character every
religion that I've ever looked at that's
pretty much it yeah right and that's
never been attractive to me like how
could you know if you did enough of the
things and like I do I don't want to
live life like well like I don't know I
I didn't bow enough I didn't pray enough
I didn't I didn't do that I didn't do
the right I gave nine percent not ten
percent I gave nine percent not ten
percent I don't know I mean like at what
point do I you know click over there's
even I mean you know TV shows based on
the good place right yes it's like you
know this ultimate weighing machines
like all the good things and all the bad
things so all that just seemed like it
just didn't seem right
then I experienced
what I would call this big realization I
remember the first time I heard what
Christians call the good news so the
good news is
God loves you
now as you currently are
so therefore follow him not do all the
things to earn God's love so it's the
incomplete it's a great reversal right
is the great reversal that's why I don't
think that actually following Jesus is a
religion it's actually a really
interesting like there's a whole
philosophical well if you think about it
is every other religion says do these
things and you'll get favor in this life
in the next so do these things the doing
the achieving is the key to the religion
right
in Christianity it's reversed so I don't
think there's anything I can do to earn
God's love
and there's no way for me to lose God's
love
right all God calls me to do is to
follow him as the one true king
right so I'm adopted as a son of the
most high King I'm royalty which means a
very odd thing right but your royalty
under a king who's crucified under a
king who preaches humility who preaches
self-sacrifice right so it is the great
reversal I'm not trying to give to
charity in order to earn God's love I'm
not trying to you know not look at
pornography or do whatever to earn God's
love like I think I know now God loves
me and therefore I want to follow him
because I care about him because I'm in
a relationship with him like if I'm
friends with you and I have care for you
and you say to me hey will you go do
this thing with me
well why do I do it am I doing it to
earn our friendship I guess that's one
way to look at the relationship it
doesn't seem very satisfying well how do
I know if I go on enough trips with you
or do enough of things am I going to
earn right but this is a very like
utilitarian approach to relationship
that is what I would call the religious
approach to relationship right
there's no achievement
in following Jesus
the work's already been done right like
Jesus on the cross it's conquering it's
actually the The Darkest Day this is
what we call Good Friday right it was
The Darkest Day when Jesus was was
crucified looked like the darkest day
was actually his enthronement right he
was put onto the throne he defeated sin
and death right and so what it's when I
heard that for the first time I was like
that is too good to be true that just
can't that can't happen right because
one my pride said my Works matter
like I want to be a good person
have you ever struggled to be a good
person I know I have I think every
single human everyone struggles to be a
good person right right it's the whole
idea of uh everyone is a sinner
everyone's a sinner in need of Grace
right we need a savior I think as I got
older I also realized when I was young I
didn't need a savior
right I can save myself I had this whole
world ahead of me right when I was older
things were going to be better when I
was older I was going to know all these
things I was gonna be able to do all
these things and I was gonna I was gonna
not need help right I was gonna be
autonomous independent and as you get
older you realize like that's the exact
opposite of reality like we are frail
future is not secured right I mean I've
had enough friends now die I had a guy
the other day he emailed me at 8 17 p.m
and he died in the middle of the night
he was 35 years old wow
Future's not a security right we are we
are way more frail than we realized and
so what it really came down to me was
okay I heard this completely new way of
looking at the world and there were
people who believed it who were deeply
thoughtful
I can barely remember what I had for
lunch yesterday how in the world could I
know what happened 2000 years ago
it seemed like an impossibility to me
so one of the friends that I had who's
unbelievable PhD and he said
why don't you go and research that see
what you think so I just started
studying the person of Jesus and I
started okay what did he actually say
because we got this movie caricature of
this like Lilly white Southern church
setting right it was like mildly racist
and like you know people are all trying
to earn things and you know be good
don't have sex give money to charity do
all these things right and then behind
the scenes there's like this very
cynical view of like everyone's
indulging in all these sins and it's all
terrible and by the way people are
sinners you know one of the things that
I I heard I think it was C.S Lewis who
said it was like church is a hospital
for Sinners not a museum of saints so if
you go into a church and you see a whole
bunch of people who you think are like
terrible good news that they're there
because you should have seen him
beforehand right yes and by the way when
I started looking at my own heart and I
realized how dark I was I said hey maybe
this is a place for me but in the
resurrection of Jesus I actually found
the answer and and so if you look at
what Jesus said Jesus thought very
highly of the scriptures the Hebrew
scriptures that were before him he said
that he didn't come to abolish the
scriptures he came to fulfill them so he
thought very highly of them so basically
the entire
religion of Christianity if you want to
call it that following Jesus hinges on
the resurrection of Jesus
if you don't believe Jesus was God and
you don't believe in the resurrection
you're just not a you're not a Christian
like I just don't know how to say it
like you can be something you be you can
be christian-like you can you can be
Christian curious I don't know whatever
you would call it but you're not a
Christian right and I never thought I
would get there I never thought I would
actually believe that Jesus was
resurrected I never thought he defeated
sin and death like like the actual
literal rising from the dead
if you go back there is incredible
evidence we have more evidence for the
resurrection of Christ than we do for
any other historical event in history
literally wow you just got to go and do
the work
I did the work I spent years pouring
over I did not become it wasn't like I
went from being an atheist to all of a
sudden it was like some light like light
switch flipped and I was a Christian
right like it didn't work like that at
all for me I had to grind and grind and
grind and ultimately realize that the
evidence became overwhelming do you know
the founder of the Aspen Institute he
did the exact same thing he did it in
his 70s his late 70s this guy who
started the Aspen Institute one of the
most world-renowned Institutes of
knowledge right is this this sort of
um Hall of ideas right and brings in
world class thinkers from around the
world
literally became a Christian in his
early 80s after studying the person of
Jesus he shocked everyone like Aspen
student not a religious organization
shocked everyone because he did the work
and so you know look I I can tell you
that
the freedom I feel the love that I feel
the life that I have I can't even
imagine what my life would be now
without Jesus I can't even imagine when
you went to do the work yeah what were
the one or two things if somebody's
watching this to say Okay I want to go
do that too they would send them to
yeah well first of all I'd have them
read
um so there's four gospels uh Matthew
Mark Luke and John
um I would have them pick one it doesn't
really matter they're all kind of
written to a slightly different
audiences they have slightly different
um details
um in them but like just get a basis and
just slowly start reading through the
gospels and and find out who Jesus
actually was to start because you're
gonna have to get a basis of knowledge
right and you can't get it from like
popular culture it's just so screwed up
and and by the way most people if you
ask most Christians actually who say
they're they're like Christians
especially in cultural Christian areas
describe what Christianity is they would
actually probably describe it more
closely to what you know we would call
religion like I'm trying to earn my way
to God's love like it is this very
counterintuitive and highly offensive
thing to experience the love of God
because it levels everyone there's no
good there's no bad we're all on the
same level field right which is highly
humbling I would say if you start there
um and then there are just a number of
books about the resurrection I think the
resume direction is the key piece Paul
who wrote most of the New Testament used
to be Saul of Tarsus was a persecutor of
Christians actually killed Christians
and then had a experience with Jesus and
became Paul who was a devout believer
and and like I said an apostle and wrote
most of the New Testament so you can
look at these different lives lives of
Jesus's half-brother James is a great
example of James was it literally says
it multiple times in in the scriptures
like James was skeptical James thought
like his brother was out of his mind
right it's like you can imagine like
what if you're one of your brothers
claimed to be God right he probably has
when you know exactly punched him you
punched them right you're right right
you come in you're like you're an idiot
come on back home right well James did
that to his brother Jesus right well
then James who wrote the the the the
Book of James later says I am a servant
of Christ and by the way he went to his
death professing the Divinity of his
brother his half-brother like there are
just these lies and it's really hard to
explain it
um other than
you have to make sense of Jesus either
Jesus was who he says he was
or he was a Madman a lunatic and a liar
and like everyone I think has to come to
the conclusion of One Direction or the
other and um
um I can tell you it's just it's been
it's been incredible it's harder to even
describe how how different my life has
been
I love that that's a great way to
describe both religion but also I think
your journey
um where can we send people to find you
on the internet find out more about
permanent Equity or if they happen to be
listening to this Naval business they
would love to partner or sell to you
guys yeah uh we're available uh
permanentequity.com there's tremendous
amount of information
um uh I'm on Twitter so at brand B sure
my my DMs are open I try to be active
depending on how what delusion I'm sure
you get the same thing it comes and kind
of fits and spurts
um yeah those would be the kind of the
two primary ways on LinkedIn if you want
to look me up there but um yeah you can
be reached I can be reached yeah for
sure yeah happy to connect with people
thank you so much for doing this I
always learn something every time we
talk and uh I love just the approach
that you guys take uh the success is
kind of the icing on the cake but I
think more people who could figure out
how do you play kind of these long-term
games do things uh hopefully the right
way is uh is good for the world so I
appreciate it we'll definitely do it
again in the future thanks for having me
on man good to see you